VERY LATEST ON SIDNEY POWELL’S
INVESTIGATION INTO VOTER FRAUD
IN THIS ELECTION BUT FIRST, YOU
MIGHT’VE SEEN DUCO
MICHIGAN STATE LEGISLATORS MET
AT THE WHITE HOUSE, THE TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION WAS ELECTION
IRREGULARITIES IN THAT STATE.
MIGHT NOT SEEM LIKE A BIG DEAL.
A POLITICIAN’S COMING TO
WASHINGTON TO TALK TO THE HEAD
OF THEIR PARTY.
PRETTY CONVENTIONAL AND HAPPENS
A LOT.
WHAT YOU DIDN’T KNOW IS IT IS
NOW A FELONY.
A HUG I CALLED RICHARD PRIMUS
ARGUING THEY SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED FOR THEIR VISIT TO
THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE SAYS HE WORKS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN’S LAW
SCHOOL.
ACCORDING TO PROFESSOR PRIMUS,
THESE TWO LAWMAKERS ARE "BEING
VISIBLY INVITED TO A MEETING
WITH A LIKELY AGENDA INVOLVES A
FELONY OF ATTEMPTING TO BRIBE A
PUBLIC OFFICIAL."
VISIBLY INVITED?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
AND HOW EXACTLY WOULD HE KNOW
THAT BRIBES WERE OFFERED IN THE
WHITE HOUSE?
HE WOULDN’T KNOW.
NOT LIKE POLITICO WAS GOING TO
FACT-CHECK A GUY CALLED
PROFESSOR PRIMUS, SO THEY WENT
WITH IT, WHATEVER.
IT’S A CRIME TO TALK TO TRUMP,
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT.
THAT’S AN ARTICLE OF FAITH AT
MSNBC.
THE REST OF US IN AMERICA HAVE
BEEN LABORING UNDER THE ILLUSION
THAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT STILL
APPLIES IN THIS COUNTRY.
SUPPORTERS OF UNPOPULAR
PRESIDENTS DESERVE THE LENGTH
AGAINST JAIL SENTENCE AS
POSSIBLE AND AT LEAST 20 YEARS,
THE FINE PRINT ON THAT AND
THEY’VE CONFIRMED IT.
YESTERDAY, A HARVARD GRADUATE
YOU SHOULD KNOW, SOMEONE WHOSE
BLOG WAS HACKED BY RECESS TIME
TRAVELING CYBER HOOLIGANS
EXPLAINED THE STANDARD TO
VIEWERS.
>> AS HE REMAINS HOLED UP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE LIKE AN END-STAGE
DICTATOR REFUSING TO CONCEDE AND
FRANKLY TO JUST GO AWAY,
DISSOLVING INTO UNREALITY WHILE
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY REMAINS
SILENT.
AT THIS POINT, IT’S HARD TO
ARGUE WITH LIFELONG REPUBLICANS
LIKE STUART STEVENS WERE CALLING
IT SEDITION.
>> Tucker: SEDITION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THIS IS
SERIOUS.
SEDITION IS PUNISHABLE BY
DECADES IN PRISON, POSSIBLY
DEATH.
GET YOUR SCAFFOLDS READY.
ININ THE LEGAL OPINION OF AN MSN
ANCHOR, THAT’S WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT HERE.
MEANWHILE, DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS
ARE SUGGESTING THE DEATH PENALTY
IS ON THE TABLE.
DID NOT, I’M CALLING FOR THE
EVENTUAL PROSECUTION OF
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS ENABLERS
FOR THEIR MANY CRIMES AGAINST
THE UNITED STATES.
KEEP IN MIND THAT HE’S A FORMER
MAYOR OF A TOWN IN NORTHERN
NEW JERSEY.
IN NORTHERN NEW JERSEY
BUT HE’S VERY UPSET ABOUT THE
IDEA OF CORRUPTION IN POLITICS.
SO MUCH FOR DEMOCRATIC NORMS AND
PEACEFUL TRANSITIONS OF POWER
THEY SPENT FOUR YEARS LECTURING
US ABOUT.
THERE WILL BE NONE OF THAT.
NOW THEY WANT BLOOD.
BY THE WAY, JOE BIDEN HASN’T
SPOKEN UP AGAINST ANY OF THIS.
APPARENTLY, HE AGREES WITH IT.
WHAT IS THIS?
IT IS UGLY AND BAD AND
DANGEROUS, FAR MORE DANGEROUS
THAN ANYTHING RUDY GIULIANI
COULD DO AT 1,000 PRESS
CONFERENCES.
YOU’LL NOTICE THAT HE HAS NOT
CALLED FOR THE WHITE HOUSE TO
ROUND UP AND IMPRISON HIS
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
HE NEVER WILL CALL FOR THAT.
THEY GENERALLY DON’T.
WHAT A HACKED NEWSPAPER.
BUT WHO WAS EAGER TO SHOOT THE
PRISONERS?
IT’S NOT RIGHT-WINGERS, IT’S THE
OTHER SIDE AND IT ALWAYS IS THE
OTHER SIDE.
ALWAYS.
WE’VE SEEN THAT THE LAST FOUR
YEARS.
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES, MANY OF
THEM OPENLY HOSTILE TO THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION USE THE
POWER OF LAW TO PUNISH THEIR
POLITICAL ENEMIES AND YOU SAW IT
UNFOLD RIGHT ON TELEVISION.
PURSUED PROCESS CRIMES LIKE
DANGEROUS FELONIES.
AT ONE POINT, THEY SENT A
S.W.A.T. TEAM AND A TV CREW FROM
CNN TO RAID THE HOME OF AN
UNARMED 68-YEAR-OLD MAN BECAUSE
THEY CLAIMED HE HAD INFORMATION
ABOUT RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
THEY DRAGGED HIM FROM HIS HOME
LIKE HE WAS RUNNING A FENTANYL
LAB OR STOLE HIS TANK FROM A
MILITARY BASE AND AFTER THEY
HUMILIATED HIM AND DESTROYED HIS
LIFE, WE LEARNED WHAT HE ALREADY
KNEW.
HE WASN’T PART OF ANY
CONSPIRACY.
IN THE END, THEY WERE FORCED TO
DOWNGRADE TO HE MAY HAVE LIED TO
CONGRESS ONES.
THE WHOLE THING WAS A DISGRACE.
BUT SO-CALLED LIBERALS LOVED IT.
THEY CLAP LIKE SEALS AT A WATER
PARK TOTALLY DELIGHTED BY THIS
MAN SUFFERING.
>> ROGER STONE MIKE DONALD TRUMP
IS A POLITICAL CON MAN WHO IS A
SHOWMAN STICK HAS FINALLY CAUGHT
UP WITH HIM.
>> IF YOU LOOK UP THE WORD
SCUMBAG IN THE DICTIONARY, YOU
WILL SEE ROGER STONE’S PICTURE
THERE.
>> I AM JUST SO HAPPY THIS GUY
IS INDICTED AND ARRESTED.
HE IS A HORRIBLE HUMAN BEING.
HE IS A THUG.
HE IS A BULLY.
>> Tucker: THAT’S WHAT THEY’LL
SAY WHEN THEY COME FOR YOU.
IT’S SICKENING.
THEY NOT TO SCARE YOU AND MAKE
YOU WORRY ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN GOALS LIKE THAT TAKE POWER
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE WHOLE PROCESS IS INEVITABLE.
WE’VE SEEN A UNFOLD ALL OVER THE
THIRD WORLD ONLY FOR 100 YEARS
WHEN YOU POLITICIZE
LAW ENFORCEMENT, AND THEY HAVE.
WHEN THEY PROSECUTE THE
PRESIDENT’S ADVISORS FOR LYING
BUT IGNORE THE OBVIOUS LYING
FROM THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI, INTELLIGENCE WHO LIED UNDER
OATH, YOU GET WHAT WE’RE SEEING
NOW.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COMPLAINED ABOUT A POLITICIZED
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ARE NOW
SALIVATING AT THE PROSPECT OF
UNLEASHING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ON THEIR POLITICAL
ENEMIES.
BUT WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
KAMALA HARRIS HAS BEEN DOING IT
FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
>> IF HE WAS NEVER IMPEACHED,
WOULD YOU WANT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO GO FORWARD WITH THOSE
CHARGES?
>> I BELIEVE THEY WOULD HAVE NO
CHOICE AND THAT THEY SHOULD.
THERE HAS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Tucker: THERE HAS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
A WE HAVE TO HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY, SINCE THE
POLITICIAN WHO REFUSED TO SUBMIT
TO A SINGLE PRESS CONFERENCE
WHILE RUNNING AS JOE BIDEN’S
RUNNING MATE.
THE DISHONESTY IS BRAZEN AND YOU
CAN BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND WHY SO
MANY AMERICANS HAVE LOST FAITH
IN THIS INSTITUTION INCLUDING
OUR ELECTIONS BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
MANAGING THEM ARE DISHONEST AND
INCOMPETENT.
OUR LEADERS ARE DEMANDING THAT
WE SAY IN OUR HOMES WHILE THEY
DINE AT THE FRENCH LAUNDRY.
AND PUNISH YOU FOR HOW YOU VOTED
BUT IF YOU DARE TO NOTICE ANY OF
THIS, I NOTICE WHAT’S HAPPENING,
YOU ARE THE DANGEROUS LUNATIC
AND YOU GET THE DOJ ON YOUR
TRAIL.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE, THE MASS
DOES SLIP AND THEY CAN SEE WHAT
GOING ON.
OCCASIONALLY, THE MEDIA CLASS
TELLS THE TRUTH.
A PBS CORRESPONDENT, SOMEONE
WHOSE SALARY YOU HELP PAY WITH
YOUR TAX DOLLARS, AN ACTUAL
EMPLOYEE OF ACTUAL STATE MEDIA
ADMITTED THE RELENTLESS FOCUS ON
JAILING DONALD TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS ACTUALLY HELPS THE
MEDIA.
THE MEDIA UNDERSTAND THEIR
RATINGS WILL PLUMMET IF THEY’RE
FORCED TO TALK ABOUT ANYTHING
OTHER THAN DONALD TRUMP.
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO SAY AND
THEY WILL NEVER COVER JOE BIDEN.
THEY VOTED FOR JOE BIDEN.
SO THAT’S A NIGHTMARE SCENARIO.
BY CONTINUING TO HYPERVENTILATE
FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIVES,
MAYBE THEY WILL STAVE OFF A
RELEVANCE UNTIL THE MORTGAGE IS
PAID.
LISTEN CLOSELY TO THIS CLIP.
>> YOU HAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP
SELLING THIS IDEA THAT THERE IS
A DEEP STATE CONSPIRACY THEORY
AGAINST HIM, IF HE GETS
INDICTED, IF HE EVEN GOES TO
JAIL, HE MIGHT SELL THAT IDEA TO
THE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO VOTED
FOR HIM AND MIGHT BECOME EVEN
MORE POWERFUL AND THAT’S WHAT
THEY’RE REALLY SCARED ABOUT AND
WHY YOU’RE SEEING PEOPLE STAND
UP TO HIM.
>> Tucker: IS UNBELIEVABLE ON
EVERY LEVEL.
A CORRESPONDENT WHOSE CAN’T
SPEAK A GRAMMATICALLY CORRECT
SENTENCE AND THE DISHONESTY OF
IT FRAMING THIS IS ANOTHER
CLEVER CONSPIRACY BY
DONALD TRUMP, BUT OF COURSE,
IT’S ABOUT THE MEDIA.
EVERYTHING IS ABOUT THEM OF
COURSE.
THEY WANT TO KEEP TALKING ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY NEED TO KEEP TALKING ABOUT